Mark: *Maniacal laughter*
*More senseless giggling*
Mark: My dick! My dick is gone!
Bob: You guys want to see some game breaking shit?
*Table flip*
Bob: *Laughs*
Jack: Ahhh
Jack: Scared the shit outta me!
Mark: *giggles*
Bob: Alright...
Bob: Let's play this shit.
Jack: Hut! Hut!
Mark: God Dammit! Who's doing that?
Bob: *shake shake shake*
Jack: Yeah! *laughs*
Wade: Oh, You can also move around with WASD and look around the table.
Mark: Oh, that's helpful.
Jack: Ohhhh.
Bob: How do you look at your hand?
Wade: Uh... So you're gonna want to grab it like put it-
Jack: Hey! Stop it!
Wade: You-You got a thing you can put it in, in front of you put it over your name.
Jack: It's just like real life!
Mark: I got it!
Mark: I got it! Stop it!
Mark: Oh, I see your hand creeping over here...
Mark: Stay away!
Bob: I'm-It's inside the box. I can't fucking-
Mark: No no!
Bob: -control it.
Mark: It's Wade. It's Wade.
Jack: Why are you allowed to take each other's shit?
Jack: I can't fu- how do I-
Bob: Oh, what is this?
Bob: What is this?
Wade: So you can rotate this by scrolling your mousewheel.
Bob: Oh fuck, fucking just leaving with it!
Bob: JUST LEAVE IT IN PLACE, FOR SHIT'S SAKE!
Mark: WADE, WE UNDERSTAND HOW TO PLAY, WADE!
Bob: Jesus, stop it.
Jack: How do I zoom?
Jack: Okay okay okay SHUT UP!
Jack: EVERYBODY STOP!
Bob: ...*giggles*
Jack: (Reading) "When I'm President of the United States, I will create the Department of ___"
Jack: Oh yeah, how do you-?
Wade: Grab a card, you flip it over, and you put it over near the deck.
Bob: Flip it over and stick it out there, yeah.
Mark: Ahh.
Bob: Just like in REAL life.
Mark: Just, bleh.
Jack: Yeah, use your brainhole, man!
Mark: Uhh, I'm tryin' man! My brainhole's not as big as yours!
Bob: HuAh ha ha ha.(dont think dirty :D)
Bob: Alright, I'm coming, where's the pile? (Too much dirty)
Bob: Is this the pile? Boop!
Mark: Is that the pile?
Jack: Okay.
Jack: And then I drag them out and flip them?
Mark: Yeees!
Bob: Sure.
Jack: Okay.
Bob: You could Right Click on it and even Shuffle, if you so desire.
Wade: Oh yeah, you can mix it up, you can grab them and shuffle 'em like that.
Mark: Ohh, that's so COOL!
Jack: Oh that's cool.
Bob: SO cool.
Jack: Okay.
Bob: Hualalala.
Jack: "When I-" Everyone's just like, "I don't care about the game, I just wanna mess with that."
*all laugh*
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: (Reading) "When I am President of the United States, I will create the Department of __"
Jack: (Reading) "__A box without hinges, key, or lid, yet golden treasure inside is hid.__"
Wade: Ooo.
Jack: (Muttering) Fucking weak card.
Wade: Oh... (I think Wade heard you Jack.)
Jack: (Reading) "When I'm President, I will create the Department of __Jerking off into a pool of children's tears.__"
Jack: THAT is a good *laughs*
Wade: Too soon.
Mark: *laughs* That's a good Department.
Wade: Oh my goodness.
Jack: "I will create the Department of Nazis" (Too soon.)
Mark: Heh heh.
Jack: OH- KAY! (Bob drew a dick)
Mark: *laughing intensifies*
Bob: *laughs heartily*
Jack: I- STOP IT!
Bob: *laughs more* I can't! I can't, I can't.
Jack: I'm gonna have to go with the Department of Children's Pool of Tears.
Bob: *groan*
Mark: That wasn't the Department name!
Wade: I got it!
Mark: "Jerking OFF into a pool of children's tears," mister!
Bob: Yeah, alright, so does that make me the Cz- the *hard C* Czar.
Jack: The guzzar?
Wade: Yes, don't forget to draw more cards if you guys spent one.
Bob: OhH YA OH god, hang on, sorry.
Mark: Woah!
Wade: Where ya goin'?
Bob: I put it in front of me. See? It's not fun when it moves around!
Bob: Can you read it NOW? Can you read it NOW, BITCHES?!
Wade: *struggling*
Jack: What are you doing?
Bob: Alright, (Reading) "Hey, baby, come back to my place and I'll show you ___"
Jack: Umm, okay.
Bob: I'm gonna put it out here, since, that's the way, that... *mumbles*
*Jack groans in pleasure*
Jack: I'm always like, like, I could go for the, I can go for the twelve-year-old answer, or the one that I think is actually SMART.
Wade: Where did Bob... Augh, you put the card--
Bob: It's not, it's not in the middle.
Mark: Yeah, why didn't you keep it over there?
Bob: The official stack, it goes inside this box or it doesn't count.
Mark: Okay, alright then.
Bob: Well, way to flip yours over, Buddy!
Wade: You didn't flip--
*Bob is laughing*
Jack: Uh... Okay.
Bob: I'm going to shuffle it all right just chill out!
Jack: Awww! You saw what it was!
Bob: It's fine. This is fine.
Jack: Shut up!
Bob: This is fine...
Jack: Fuckos
Bob: I'm shuffling like crazy
Jack: Good lines, Buddy!
Mark: Thanks.
*Bob laughs at the apparent shape of the box*
Bob: It's a dick.
*Bob chuckles*
Bob: It's a dick!
Bob: (Reading) "Hey, Baby. Come back to my place and I'll show you..."
Bob: "...making the penises kiss."
*the guys (although they're really children) chuckle*
Bob: (Reading) "Come back to my place and I'll show you..."
Bob: "...the passage of time."
Bob: (Reading) "Come back to my place and--"
*everyone chuckles*
Bob: Oh, that one's the loser!
Bob: A real stink--
Jack: NOOOOOOO!
Bob: --real Stink-O over there!
Bob: This one? Or this one?
Jack: See? I never...
Jack: ...go for the crude ones.
Bob: This one? Or this one?
Bob: I have an idea.
*"Circus Music" by Bob plays*
Bob: Uh... I gotta go with "making the penis kiss".
Mark: *very proud* Yaaaay!
Wade: Awww my incest was wasted
Mark: Take that, Incest!
Bob: ...Penis kiss.
Wade: You can put it in your hand on the side if you want.
Mark: No! I want to show off for everybody!
Wade: Okay.
*Bob and Jack laugh*
Mark: See how great I am?
Bob: Oh so are these just like free to take -Mark:NOOOO
Bob: Oh shit you can steal things from people's hand?
Bob: Oh fuck- Jack:Yeah! Its so dumb *Bob and mark laugh*
Bob: *laughs harder*Alright I'm- I'm - I'm not gonna do it. I'm not gonna do it
Bob: I didn't do it
Mark: Yeah sure. Bob: I didn't (Are you sure about that?)
Bob: I actually didn't. Mark: Okay cool
Wade: You can see the train wreck.
Wade: WHO'S GOT JUST A PENCIL
Mark: Alright anyway, (Reading) "Jesus is ___ " Jack:mmmm
Bob: *laughing* Mark: Make it funny guys
Jack: Ahhhhh- Mark: Alright here we go, (Reading) "Jesus is drinking alone"
Mark: That's sad. Jack: Poor Jesus
Mark: (Reading) "Jesus is some douche with an acoustic guitar" Wade:*laughs* Jack:*laughs*
J,B,W:*laughing* Mark: (Reading) "Jesus is the imagination of Peter Jackson" *laughing*
Everyone: *laughing* Mark: Oh man that's funny-
Mark: No drinking alone- Wade: Aww- Mark: Sorry-
Jack: C'mon Betsy! Mark: Uhhhhhhhhh Bob:*circus music* Mark: Ay ay ay.
Mark: This one made me laugh, this is the winner.
Jack: YAAAAY! Bob: NOOOOO! Jack: Whoop Whoop! Bob: Fuck you douche bag with a guitar
Wade: Take that...Guitar. Jack: Take that bitch-
Bob and Mark: Take that and rewind it back- Mark: Oh. Jack:*chuckles* B,M:*laugh*
Jack: The big big booty go
Jack: (Goose Noise)- Mark: I'll make your booty go *Goose noise?* baby-
Mark: Just give me a chance. Jack: (Goose noise)
Bob: Oh my god- Mark: Oh my god! Wade: (Reading) "____+_____ ="
Wade: So here's how I'm gonna do it
Wade: You guys just put them like 3
Wade: In a row somewhere, I'ma go stare off.
Wade: In the distance and not look
Bob: I g- I got a solution,I got a solution. (Do you now?)
Bob: Do it like this 1,2,3 and just everyone
Bob: Keep to your own area. Mark: Ya gotta draw 2, remember-
Wade: Just don't put it in front of you so its obvious who's-
Mark: Don't forget to draw 2 more-
Bob: Oh yeah because you have to draw 2 to start.
Bob: That's right
Mark: *Dying noises or deep throating, you decide* Alright ready- Bob: Alright we're done-
Jack: *chuckles*
Wade: Oh I got far away from the table
Bob: *laughs*Wh-Where are you?
Bob: I wish I could like see where you were Wade: I'm back now
*NONSENSE* Jack:Jesus- Mark:This was hard-
Bob:*laughs* Wade:Alright holy crap okay-
Wade:So we're going to Columns not Rows?
Mark:Nono Bob:Yeah so each rose one person
*all talking over each other*
Bob:One-One person
Wade:Okay so why is there 1,2,3 up here
Jack:Cause this is our first second and third card- Bob:Thats the order
Mark:Use your brain
Jack:IF YOU WEREN'T BUSY LOOKING AT PEOPLE IN PEWS-
Wade:Well I'm sorry I wasn't watching you
Wade:Guys do all this-  Bob:*laughing*  Wade:Okay
Bob:Just flip 'em over Wade:First one "Active listening +
Wade:"Intelligent design = children on leashes".... *Bob laughs*
*Everyone but Mark laughs*
Mark: Nice, Nice  Wade: I wasn't I don't know
how we ended up here but I'm glad we did
Bob: there's a connection  Mark: I see the connection
Bob: It happens
Wade: Team-Building exercises plus wearing an octopus for a
hat equals interspecies marriage octodad
octodad
shaft plus gloryholes equals 0 and it
is children leashes
no oh yeah yeah I wanted to go Hawk I
wanted to be unpredictable predictable
you were damn come on shaft foot door oh
I know I know I should have been the
winner but am I gonna pick it what about
mine guys come back talk to a little
Mary footmark random and one thank you
now the perfect thank you
good one going on my yes great job
thanks guys
mtv's new reality show features eight
washed-up celebrities living with come
on hepatitis Rebs nadir that's it there
they go back but yeah there you go
really fast shuffle the shit out of
these terms like a boss or something
that's it that's the one that's what he
says all wait while your hand gets so
big it would be sitting here I think
your own hand is tiny but the other
people's kids all my mind all the time p
to its ok everybody new reality show
features eight washed-up celebrities
living with the inability just about the
relationship meaning of all anything for
meaningful relationships sorry my old
autism from an outbreak of small for my
god is good
oh god yeah and she is ok i know because
how dare he had always heard before
why'd you pick my old oxygen
yeah that's the first I should I feel
like their manuel because it was not
kidding okay yet maybe explaining
yourself it's not going to make things
up because I thought it was funny
because he knows you're dead why would
you even say that that's better i did
that yeah we overthink this
where oh shit I didn't have to go with
the inability to forming in this
relationship maybe had people because
not only win one that the reality show
couple what it is sounds hilarious all
together and then they can actually do
anything that I look right to call black
hired over here finally a service that
delivers blank right to your door
hmm it off yeah fucking cards alone
everyone leave my car to one of these
are my car okay okay back off man back
off man it's Wade what the fuck away but
backed up like off its cool we leave it
alone i said haha broke it
hello hello how are you just are you
just fingering it like that because I my
god damn wizard
that's how are you doing it you too
because I'm not an idiot in us right
back on it you fucking moron
right-clicking opens up my menu which is
the shuffle is the first this trice
ah yeah way would you fucking stuff with
you act old oh don't worry comes back to
cook at all does it
wait my cards are all different I have
to give him your hand tightly well I was
the waiter waiter finally I'm that
delivers britney spears that 55 right to
your door you just hit my card with your
car with the hell yeah
do I leave it's a service that delivers
full-frontal nudity right here front
door that are at the good finally the
service that delivers medieval times
dinner & tournament and right to your
front door who that I want to go back
they give you to tackle the chicken with
no you can I know it's right it's really
fun and I want to go help that's way too
hard
it was mighty hold you like hard their
ass right now you know what screw you
guys i'm getting rid of my hand
yes full-frontal nude yeah already of
service you can order a stripper
you already got four known there's no
interaction you know you can't order
britney spares b5 nobody literally just
shows up at your door and flashes you
and then
the way that's not a stripper it's
different hey yeah it's your crazy uncle
imagine if a night job stood into your
living room and gave you a chicken to
eat that always better reaction that's
not like it would be a horrible horrible
cool would that be cool idea that would
be pretty cool pretty cool something
convenient uh-huh all right
climatic and whos winning my meaning I
three
alright hey you fucking are here haha
and this is the way the world ends not
with a bang but with a blank
oh no I threw my car buff it it's always
up here comes up hits workouts up here
it's right here turn your ok you drop
the card off the edge of the table it's
just like falls into because it's really
disconcerting
let me try it try it it's really fucking
going to you like but God stuff just
disappear so everybody and hold the way
the world ends
this is the way the world ends not with
a bang but with a gadget you need to
check on you know
oh ok that's enough trouble it's just no
good here we are with this is the way
the world ends not with a bang but with
Stephen Hawking talking dirty
I like that that's good so nice out with
a bang but with sneezing farting and
coming at the same time like that
good that's an experience now with a
bang but ancient & seen him put oh why
do I think that's wait
lucky you thought that you could ah Rome
an hour ago Stephen Hawking talking
dirty
yeah it got tickets to take it's a good
one but i don't want to with ya
oh I get one Mady Jack win what
completely heart who
yes you should have picked medieval
times I got ride sorry I'm being the
phoniest oh you're not funny at all not
about how funny you are it's about how
you use it it's the motion of the ocean
talking about your hell yeah it's a grab
trip I tell you the ruler of traffic
with the track
up girth it's a trap lose weight
oh the donald rumsfeld approval and I
Drive what's the goal but I've got all
out of here do not measure the girls of
my eyes re your grower not a show i can
hook up nothing
it's a trap all those giving money to a
homeless person
it's a dry up I go to the homeless
that's what oh my god what I I'm with
you on that one
yes you get sick lat huh
whoa who wrote fuck you with green
writing mysteries at the time for their
fucking good fucking do that they're
talking about what's up i cleaned it up
can you clean up your brain with your
terrible judgment could you do that
oh so maybe if you able to pick one of
my cards one time oh really
whoa why do you have to get out of my
house haha just whoa you're gonna have
compared Bob what are you doing what
it's fine this is fun and let's go to
talk about about read it let's just read
a bit everything's fine
billy mays here for blank what this
won't pass cheeks
hell yeah fuckin suction cup nipples are
you drawing and it's not even remotely
what I thought you were drawing but this
is a butthole and he'll tip well yeah I
suppose the other minerals
okay everybody shut up and pay attention
okay
billy mays here for a crippling OCD the
fact that the OC is so close together
and you got you LOL these you gotta
really yelled triggering my OCD needs
its own space
well I thought I therefore not your
ballot had because that can keep this
course
perfect thanks man probably very here
for letting everyone down
you never left ok that's the winner
see ya in a real fuck you Wade
anyway I am second car
after you read it out loud like that was
awesome I don't go its last round will
go out
oh my god made it about a crack whoever
just true this is sick box Rach wait a
great line
my plan for world domination begins with
right nipple shuffle the shit out of it
for second shot from broad you shuffle
shuffle shuffle shuffle things shopping
if I you know scheffler I plan for world
domination begins with fuck give me one
of those fuckers Jenny awkwardly trying
to seduce makin fillion Jenni John Jenni
food any good yeah i don't know i know
what that I plan for world domination
begins with unlimited soup salad and
bread oh I'm hungry something good
my plan for world domination begins with
pooping as quietly as possible man has
been there because i'm going to what
extent that why you never been a
situation where you to poop as quietly
as possible but not a library i go to
hell for leather and all i got your in
the bathroom and someone you know walked
in and you're just like no I got you
oh my god it made a billion yeah you're
like your ear weather in the bathroom
like rite hospital later in the bathroom
in the kitchen yeah yeah and you're like
five feet away
Maddie's mom is cooking dinner right now
please
that's the time when you should poop the
loudest yeah that were in your
involvement
I'm here to attack which letter know
that literally no yeah
Boggs here however you discarding my
first that's great yeah I gotta go to
move we gotta go it's pooping it's quiet
yay
yeah I'm with the jacket aren't everyone
off bad and I'm great
okay sure sure we go with that mr. few
cases haha yeah that's all I got that
one God out cute collectively all of the
combined have the same number of cards
to go and what did you bring for show
until lower
oh shitty fucking cards against humanity
cards we already stop don't stop up here
we go ok and what did you bring for show
as it stops just got it haha first-class
not gonna have to take sex toys that uh
a crappy little sister you're done but
you prepare for all that you again why
horrible one-stop I'm gonna get you the
one who said that thing about that other
thing I'm going to judge this based on
what I'd be most impressed at a
show-and-tell and that's that presses oh
haha not make this process I like the
Sixers yeah
god fucking dammit Oh like you don't
have enough cards ready but that I
weighed I mean I'm proud of you for
admitting it haha
and for what you believe in that's
definitely a tent-like impressive you
yeah where you write that upside-down
way that's pretty cool yeah he's got
buddy good job y'all underline it so
everyone can read it easily queen here
though they're all this is the last
underlies our o.o what I won't win I
wonder who's gonna pick okay yeah i was
there just wasn't very good idea to be
like that's where I don't know how about
creating you were all you're right my
bad go ahead huh what does don't want
quiet in your chinese food like this
ship to that are you
mm what city card I think anybody should
change to crappy little hard
what are you having fun i will show you
like oh I have the perfect car and I
want different card are we doing now in
bookstores the desk wait wait this is I
think this is how this works
sure pop the balloons are in midair
why what don't be a what you're trying
to do was play the first car good yeah
that's how it looks
I don't know where it is yeah yeah what
you want to find your chinese food that
way you do that's a lot of stole one of
my cards what the fuck i didn't sorry
about i know its back okay I thought I
only had six but what is happening to
the new blade why are you shuffling so
poorly that right what I think pink what
do i fire triangle the Hamburglar I
would not want to find that my chinese
like all of him all of the big picture
just might be planning a matter of him
was gonna find a chinese food a bloody
place of God but that is correct that
that would be bad until ho do not worry
if the me general so what happened about
the baby although yes it's good with
general self what I want me general self
what happened with the / transferred
boohoo 40 like honeymoon day it's ok
boom chick has a boo-boo
I think of all these I don't want the
point of bloody past yeah i agree with
I'll yeah see I gotta go but how could
you just do this to him he's got three
of my tax but now I had one I fuckin had
one that you steal my card if another
one just throwing about the size of a
that I had quite a character three
I don't think so i don't recall you
having I don't recall either that guy
asked to play yeah that's yeah
any card yeah all done because golf
yeah that one you have to lowes yeah
everybody born I agree Bob one I wrote
that my notebook i did I was like you
know what rules you know what Bob when
check it out check it out you can see it
in the notebook wait wait no hang on
wait I can't wait for it wait Bob
this one okay
oh you think just because you threw the
grenade attacks you fronted by what is
this over here supposed to be a penis